J'sais pas si vous avez remarqué, mais dans les pubs, les gens sont bizarres
bref c'est les pubs versus la vie 2, c'est parti !
Dans les pubs !
Je suis passé sé choche
Je suis passé ssé coche
Ouais je suis passé ché choche
Je suis passé chez Sosh.
C'est compliqué à dire ? Non ça ne l'est pas !
Arrêtez d'prendre des gogoles dans votre pub. Tout le monde arrive à le dire !
Dans les pubs ~
Un bueno ?
Ouais, c'est le dernier. Dommage pour toi ! *rires*
- Ah bah, c'est cool, tu l'as bien pris !
- Quoi ?
Bah ta nouvelle voiture ! Abîmée par maman !
Kinder Bueno, ...
Dans la vie !
- C'est le dernier, dommage pour toi !
- Ah bah c'est cool tu l'as bien pris
- Quoi ?
- Bah ta nouvelle voiture, abîmée par maman
QUOI, ELLE A FAIT QUOI ?!
T'ES VRAIMENT QU'UNE CONNE HEIN
NE FAIS PAS SEMBLANT JE SAIS TOUT
- Non mais...
- T'FAÇON J'AURAIS JAMAIS DÛ T'ÉPOUSER JE LE SAVAIS !
LE GAMIN N'EST PAS DE MOI ? MAIS J'M'EN BATS LES COUILLES DU GAMIN !
IL A TA GUEULE DE CONNE, IL VEUT JUSTE DES BUENO DE MERDE ! IL FAIT RIEN DE SA VIE ! MERDE !
T'façon, j'ai plus faim...
QUELLE FAMILLE DE MERDE !
Dans les publicités !
[Musique de la pub iPhone 7]
Dans la vie réelle !
Regarde ce que je viens de filmer.
C'est flou, on voit rien, il y a des gouttes sur l'objectif...
Ah oui, merde.
Pourquoi tu filmes un arrosage automatique aussi ?
Euh... comme c'est en étanche..
Ça sert à rien, mec. C'est nul. T'es con, putain.
Mais ouais, mais la 4K...
Nan t'es con !
Dans les pubs
[Musique de la pub Herta]
*voix-off de la pub* Le Bon Paris, de Herta.
Dans la vie
Pourquoi moi j'ai pas mon jambon enroulé et les tomates-cerises ?
Ah t'aimes pas mon jambon ?!
BAH J'VAIS T'EN CHERCHER UN AUTRE, TIENS !
Dans ce qu'on peut voir dans les pubs
Pour moi, la base d'une relation épanouie, c'est de partager des passions et des valeurs communes.
Ce qu'on peut voir dans la vie.
Pour moi, la base d'une relation épanouie...
...c'est de rencontrer que des riches sur Internet !
Ah bah oui, nan mais... faut arrêter les conneries,
Imaginez, je discute avec une pauvre...
OU PIRE ! Je discute avec une moche ! *rires* Moi avec une moche ? Non pas du tout en vrai nous, c'est entre riches !
DANS LES PUBS!
*en chantant* Pour une boîte, ça demande du temps
Pourquoi vous chantez ?
Dans la vie !
*en chantant* Pour une boîte, ça demande du temps
MERDE, ON CHANTE PAS DANS UNE BANQUE !
BARREZ-VOUS !
Je me barre, désolé, c'est la pub qui m'a...
Dans les pubs !
CITYA ENVIE D'UN APPART' , VA VOIR CITYA , ILS PRENDRONT SOINS DE TOI *en chantant*
Et...dans la vie
L' appartement est super, je le prends !
Ah nan mais c'est mort... Votre dossier est zéro, là...
CITYA ENVIE D'UN APPART', VA VOIR... *en chantant*
MAIS FERME LA !!!
Bon, ton dossier est pourri, là ...
Tu t'casses !
Ne chantez pas ! CITYA c'est d'la merde, ça marche pas du tout...
Je ris, j'éternue..
J'ai des fuites urinaires !
J'ai découvert une protection INCROYABLE, dans une serviette vraiment très fine
Dans la vie !
Je ris, j'éternue..
J'ai des fuites urinaires !
*Echo* Mais que ce que je fais là ?
Je voulais être comédienne moi, monter sur scène, réciter du Molière, pas faire une pub pour des couches !
Qu'est-ce que j'ai loupé dans mon parcours pour me retrouver ici ?
J'ai découvert une protection INCROYABLE dans une serviette vraiment très fine, avec Always Discreet !
*Echo* Aidez-moi, s'il vous plaît ! J'ai besoin d'aide !
En plus elles sont super épaisses ces serviettes !
Dans les pubs !
*Il fait de la musique avec ses doigts*
Et toi, tu fais quoi avec des doigts ?
Dans la vie !
*musique avec ses doigts*
Quoi, t'aimes pas ?
J'aime pas quoi, au fait ?
Mec ça fait 10 ans que j'apprends à faire ça ! C'est stylé !
Non mais en 10 ans t'apprends un instrument, de la guitare...
PUTAIN, mais tous le monde me dit ça ! Ça m'énerve !
*Claque ses doigts*
Non ! Mais si, si c'est très bien ce que tu fais !
Parce qu.. ouais
Mmmhh... Dans les pubs
- Mais il faut de l'argent pour se développer.
- J'ai une banque.
Dans la vie
Mais il faut de l'argent pour se développer.
Oui... Mais, euh... Pourquoi on parle de mon compte en banque dans la rue, là ?
Devant tout le monde ? On peut pas faire ça dans un bureau, comme d'habitude ? Euh...
Eh, mais c'est madame Morin, c'est ma prof de maths ! Vous avez des problèmes de thunes ?
Elle est dans le rouge ! Elle a dépensé 1700 balles dans des SMS pour Secret Story !
Oh la bouffonne, mais attends je vais appeler tous le monde !
On peut aller dans un petit bureau, c'est bien un petit bureau !
Dans les pubs
La mycose de l’ongle est contagieuse et paraît peu hygiénique
Traitez-la IMMEDIATEMENT
Excilor
Dans la vie.
*Dégoutée*
Bon, bah je vais mettre du verni on y verra que du feu.
Hop.
À ce qu'on peut voir dans les pubs.
Le balais Swiffer nettoie partout dans la maison
Et... Ce que qu'on peut voir dans la vie...
T'as vu, ça marche bien, hein !
Non mais mec... C'est dégueulasse chez toi. En fait, ON PEUT PAS MARCHER
Ça j'utilise Swiffer et..
ARRÊTE C'EST DÉGUEULASSE !
DANS LES PUBS
Retrouvez l'efficacité Cillit Bang !
DANS LA VIE
Mais mec c'est quoi cette cuisine dégueulasse, là ?!
Oui mais j'ai Cillit Bang.
MAIS NON C'EST PAS CA, C'EST... JUSTE : REGARDE!
SOIS PROPRE UN MOMENT ! Y'A TOUT QUI PUE MON GARS, OH REGARDE !!
En la publicidad
Et la deuxième paire offerte, je peux la choisir...
Librement, dans tout le magasin.
Et celle-là ?
Oui, aussi !
Dans la vie
Et celle-là ?
Non, ça c'est mes lunettes.
Ah, mais c'est celle que j'ai choisi !
- Elles me plaisent beaucoup !
- Non !
- Lâchez...
- Je veux... je veux ces lunettes !
- C'est mes lunettes !
- Elle est con !
- Je veux ce modèle !
- J'ai choisi ce modèle !
- C'est mes lunettes !
- C'est MES lunettes !
- Donnez-les moi !
- Y'EN A PLEIN D'AUTRES DERRIÈRE !
- JE VEUX CE MODÈLE !
Vous êtes bientôt 10 millions d’abonnés à ma chaîne YouTube.
C'est un truc de malade, vous êtes bientôt 10 millions !
Je vous le cache pas, je prépare une vidéo spéciale pour l'occasion
Un truc un peu dingue que j'ai jamais fait sur ma chaîne, un truc...
Une aventure à vivre, on peut dire ça comme ça !
Du coup, je lance officiellement...
L'objectif 10 millions d'abonnés !
C'est officiel,
On peut le faire !
"We can do it" ça veut dire "On peut le faire" en Américain
Je compte sur vous !